the Joe Rogan experience I thought Chris
Hedges was gonna be six five when I met
him and he's saying he's a normal guy
yeah it's normal that talk if you met
Chris Cuomo Fredo Fredo Fredo no he'll
read my [ __ ] if I do he'll wreck your
[ __ ] and stare was so revealing who are
you are you 16 but you know that Fredo
is the N word for oh we've all said
we've all said we've been saying that
for years
get fed it fettuccine ln word that is so
[ __ ] dumb this save the idea that he
thought that he could pass out off and
he knew they were filming right yes yeah
how do you not so it's like saying that
to an italian-american is like using the
n-word like oh is it really
guess what here's the thing about being
Italian there's no word for us there's
no word for us you can call me a Guinea
you can call me a [ __ ] it's like
okay doesn't work there's no word they
don't work they work for my
grandfather's day I used to talk to my
grandfather because you know he was an
immigrant and he came over from Italy
and he told me all the horrible [ __ ]
kids in school would say to him all the
horrible [ __ ] people history yeah
guineas back then were they were they
were talked to like trash immigrants
like they were they wanted them to go
home they didn't want him there and
there was a lot of dispute between the
Irish and the Italian yeah once were
thought of the way a lot of racist
people think of Mexicans like they're
coming over here to take our arms that
come up there infesting our neighborhood
with their smells and their food in
there they want to talk their language
like my grandparents always spoke
Italian in the house always they smell
great that's what you like I love
Italian food so it smells great but they
always talked Italian my grandmother and
my grandfather always spoke at town each
other yeah they lived in an Italian
neighborhood up until it changed
they lived in Newark New Jersey okay
which was all town so it seems like
every wave of immigrants becomes the new
horrible person right so I grew up
because when I was Irish and they talk
about how the no Irish need apply all
that stuff and then you know I mean
that's what it's just there's waves of
this right
now the wave is you know Mexicans are
the scapegoats but you know there's that
documentary they did a while back a day
with no Mexicans uh-huh but it's true
everything would [ __ ] shut down
especially Los Angeles no kidding but
most of the country most of the country
this is the dirty secret about the
United States of America is that we rely
a lot of it shouldn't say we a lot of
Industry podcasters doesn't really rely
on the illegal immigrants but a lot of
industries rely on illegal immigrants
and it's it's a [ __ ] up situation to
be in for them because they really don't
have a path to become legal even if
they've been proven right for decade
after decade that they're a viable
contributing part of our culture because
they got over here illegally even if
they came over here as a child that we
can't we can't let you stay you know and
that's another thing you know the
immigration had they've been scapegoated
since as far as I can remember Bill
Clinton so Bill Clinton if you go back
there c-span videos of him saying
Mexicans coming here taking our jobs and
all that stuff used he did all that
stuff and Hillary Clinton she bragged
that she voted for a border wall so our
barrier it was a fence in some places
but she bragged used to brag about it
and so then Trump comes along and turns
it up another notch and they're like
this guy's a [ __ ] yeah it's like no you
guys went so I make this point he just
says it away this yeah it's very
offensive and it's wrong right when he
of course it is but what I'm saying is
he's building off of a bunch of [ __ ]
that's offensive and wrong just like
when they tweeted out those so you find
out this is what I say there oh he
banned all the Muslims at the airport
then you find out why are they at the
airport Brock Obama has been bombing
them for eight [ __ ] years straight he
dropped 26,000 but they ran out of Bob's
then you find out he's putting
immigrants in cages you find out about
Barack Obama built those cages then you
say find out that Trump is gassing
immigrants at the border and you find
out Barack Obama also gassed immigrants
at the border and they should be honored
they were gassed by the lesser of two
evils so there is the silver lining and
it's finally starting to come out
because the Democrats have run this
Russia gate to that it's done they did
the mullet report it's over he concluded
there is no collusion it's over so now
they moved on to impeachment but now
he's bombing so they're finally starting
to talk about the War Powers Act there's
finally talk but nobody's talking about
cutting the Pentagon budget did you hear
do you hear that I don't hear no do you
think the the main the main thing about
impeachment is supposedly that he tried
to get Ukraine to investigate his
political pride Joe Biden right that's
the main thing that's what they say take
that out and there's basically nothing
right and and and people aren't really
that upset that he tried to half the
country for sure aren't upset that he
tried to investigate you how many people
are clinging to this as if this is a
rich impeachment makes sense because
they think that he's not presidential
that's it yeah that as aaron Matei says
who's the only guy I know who won an
award for his Russia gate coverage
because he debunked it like a good
reporter supposed to do what he he
always makes the point that Trump is not
a suitable steward of imperialism and
they think he puts an ugly face on the
[ __ ] we've been this is what I've this
is the Trump puts an ugly face on the
stuff we've been doing all along and so
now people are gonna be more aware of it
and we would have been more aware of it
if the Democrats would have actually
opposed him on substance instead of
Russia gay he says things sometimes the
ego you were just allowed to write your
own speech like women when he was
talking about Baghdadi that he died like
a dog and you're like what you're
allowed to say that he died like a dog
or how about that this is the weird
thing that he uses Twitter to threaten
other countries like when he was talking
about Iran that if they respond they
will respond in perhaps a
disproportionate manner mm-hmm like
you're using Twitter
mm-hmm to threat like nobody ever
thought that there was gonna be this
sort of a venue for a president to just
just have mouth diarrhea mm-hmm and
that's why they I mean I really believe
that's a big reason why a lot of the
establishment wants to get rid of him
because he makes them look bad because
they agree with this policies the
Democrats just gave him everything he
wanted they paid for his [ __ ] border
wall they gave him expanded spying
powers they gave him my extra 131
billion to go bomb people they helped
fast-track as judges they [ __ ] also
helped him deregulate Wall Street what
the [ __ ] aren't they doing for him and
that's why we have Donald Trump
[Applause]